Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Image denoising is an area where we have a
noisy image as an input, and we wish to get
a clear, noise-free image.
Neural network-based solutions are amazing
at this, because we can feed them a large
amount of training data with noisy inputs
and clear outputs.
And if we do that, during the training process,
the neural network will be able to learn the
concept of noise, and when presented with
a new, previously unseen noisy image, it will
be able to clear it up.
However, with light transport simulations,
creating a noisy image means following the
path of millions and millions of light rays,
which can take up to hours per training sample.
And we need thousands, or potentially hundreds
of thousands of these!
There are also other cases where creating
the clean images for the training set is not
just expensive, but flat out impossible.
Low-light photography, astronomical imaging,
or magnetic resonance imaging, MRI in short
are great examples of this.
In these cases, we cannot use our neural networks
simply because we cannot build such a training
set as we don't have access to the clear images.
In this collaboration between NVIDIA, Aalto
University and MIT, scientists came up with
an insane idea: let's try to train a neural
network without clear images and use only
noisy data.
Normally, we would say that this is clearly
impossible and end this research project.
However, they show that under a suitable set
of constraints, for instance, one reasonable
assumption about the distribution of the noise
opens up the possibility of restoring noisy
signals without seeing clean ones.
This is an insane idea that actually works,
and can help us restore images with significant
outlier content.
Not only that, but it is also shown that this
technique can do close to or just as well
as other previously known techniques that
have access to clean images.
You can look at these images, many of which
have many different kinds of noise, like camera
noise, noise from light transport simulations,
MRI imaging, and images severely corrupted
with a ton of random text.
The usual limitations apply, in short, it
of course cannot possibly recover content
if we cut out a bigger region from our images.
This severely hamstrung training process can
be compared to a regular neural denoiser that
has access to the clean images, and the differences
are negligible most of the time.
So how about that, we can teach a neural network
to denoise without ever showing it the concept
of denoising.
Just the thought of this boggles my mind so
much it keeps me up at night.
This is such a remarkable concept - I hope
there will soon be followup papers that extend
this idea to other problems as well.
If you enjoyed this episode and you feel,
that about 8 of these videos a month is worth
a dollar, please consider supporting us on
Patreon.
We use these funds to make better videos for
you, and a small portion is also used to fund
research conferences.
You can find us at patreon.com/TwoMinutePapers
and there is also a link to it in the video
description.
You know the drill, one dollar is almost nothing,
but it keeps the papers coming.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!